space shifts aliens fighting alien
fighting and Rihanna wearing a magic hat
we're going to jump into the new
valerian and the city of a thousand suns
trailer to see what it can tell us about
the film the film is based on the French
comic book valerian and Laura line which
debuted in 1967 specifically the story
pulls from volume 6 of that series
called ambassador of shadows it's one of
the best-selling comics in France and
has influenced numerous sci-fi films
including Star Wars and Luc Besson Zone
Fifth Element comic book fans will also
recognize the two stars Cara Delevingne
played in Chandra since Suicide Squad
and Dane DeHaan was the Green Goblin an
amazing spider-man 2 speaking of Fifth
Element
from the look of the cityscape with its
clustered flying car traffic this Lilu
like fall shot from above to the color
palette of the film itself it's very
clear this film was made with an
understanding of its audience we all
love Fifth Element this shot of Rihanna
approaching valerian is pretty closely
reminiscent to the plot Lagoona korben
Dallas scene luc besson put together a
600 page Bible on Alfa the city the
movie is based in and the 200 a lien
species that inhabited so far we've seen
nowhere near that amount so there's
going to be plenty left to see when the
movie finally drops the trailer shows an
incredible amount of unique settings and
we can't wait to find out where the hell
they actually are this film has 2,700
visual effects shots in order to bring
the universe to life and the budget
thanks for asking
Besson had a hundred and eighty million
dollars to spend making this the most
expensive European film ever made by
comparison the Fifth Element cost 90
million and it was flippin fantastic so
according to that math this movie is
going to be twice as good sorry for
being such a peb element fanboy you
don't mind the no sure Oh
the film's us release is July 2017 so to
keep yourself busy go read the wiki's
about it on comic vine for more on your
favorite comic books TV shows and movies
check out gamespot universe